it's time for some good vibes of the day
uh yeah sean mendes is the latest celeb
to be put through vanity fair's lie
detector test where he nervously laughs
through over 15 minutes of questions
topics included his girlfriend amelia
cabello taylor swift and notably whether
he and justin bieber ever talked about
that time
shawn
had the date with haley baldwin at the
met gala and all that sort of
awkwardness yep
uh see you back here tomorrow on youtube
and on facebook at 12 15 eastern take it
away sean
thanks morgan i got justin bieber yeah
did the met gala get brought up when we
met no
never talked about that
he's telling the truth yeah yeah
okay let's move on
you toured with taylor swift in 2015.
have you remained friends ever since
yeah
i just think this photo's so funny it
looks so big and awkward
do you guys still text
yeah
i i always am asking her for advice on
music
when was the last time he texted
maybe
a month ago
so whatever that counts for as still
texting
do you approve of taylor's current
boyfriend joe allen i've never
personally met joe
but he looks like a he looks like a
sweet guy
you're not telling the truth you're
being deceptive i'm lying a little bit
yes i mean he's kind of got a little bit
of a villain look about him i i mean he
looks like a nice guy but like it
he he like at any like
movement could turn into a villain you
know but
he's got really blue eyes and i struggle
with like the eyes that blue you know
like i find it easier to trust brown
eyes is it fair to say tarzan likes mom
more no
no no no i wouldn't even go and say he
likes me more
yes
would camila say that i think she would
through her teeth say it